in a boston courtroom friday two parents
were found guilty in connection with an
elaborate nationwide college admissions
cheating scandal it was the first trial
in the so-called varsity blues case
where wealthy parents tried to get their
children into elite colleges by
falsifying extra exams and bribing
coaches to treat the children as
recruited athletes nancy chen has more
a federal jury found john wilson and
kamal abdulaziz guilty on all counts
ranging from wire fraud to bribery they
broke the law
and now they face the consequences
prosecutors say the men paid a combined
1.5 million dollars to rick singer a
college admissions consultant and the
mastermind behind an eight-year scheme
where he helped children from wealthy
families get into prestigious schools
john wilson and gamal abdelaziz used
fraud and bribery to get what they
wanted
what they did was an affront dozens of
parents and college officials have been
charged 48 people have either pleaded or
planned to plead guilty including stars
lori lockland and felicity hoffman who
both spent a short time in prison wilson
paid singer 220 thousand dollars to get
his son into usc and a million dollars
for his twin daughters to attend harvard
and stanford abdulaziz gave 300 thousand
dollars to get his daughter into usc as
a basketball recruit even though she
didn't make her varsity team in high
school prosecutors played fbi wiretap
calls during the trial to show how
abdelaziz and singer conspired together
so i just want to make sure our stories
are together i'm going to essentially
say that your 300 thousand dollar
payment
was made to our foundation to help
underserved kids okay
eric rosen the former lead prosecutor in
this case says these parents donations
cross the line the central theme from
the beginning is
if something involves lies and cheating
it's probably not legitimate and i think
the jury agreed with that here the most
serious charges in this case could mean
up to 20 years in prison with sentencing
scheduled for february for cbs saturday
morning nancy chen boston